Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Fue una de las figuras
más influyentes
del siglo XX,
cambió para siempre el curso
de uno de los países
más extensos del mundo.
Pero ¿fue un héroe
que derrocó a una
tiranía opresiva
o un villano que la
reemplazó por otra?
Es hora de poner
a Lenin en el estrado
en la Historia contra Lenin.
"Orden, orden, mmm.
¿No fue su culpa que
la banda se separara?"
"Su señoría, este es
Vladimir Ilich Ulianov,
alias Lenin, el agitador
que ayudó a derrocar al zar
Nicolás II de Rusia en 1917
y fundó la Unión Soviética,
una de las peores dictaduras
del siglo XX".
"Ohh".
"El zar era un tirano sangriento
bajo el cual las masas trabajaban
en condiciones de esclavitud".
"Esto es una basura.
La servidumbre ya se
había abolido en 1861".
"Y reemplazado por algo peor.
Los patrones trataban
a los obreros
peor que los antiguos
señores feudales.
Y a diferencia de
los señores feudales,
estaban siempre allí.
Los trabajadores rusos
trabajaban 11 horas al día
y recibían los salarios
más bajos de Europa".
"Pero el zar Nicolás hizo leyes
para proteger a los trabajadores".
"De mala gana hizo lo mínimo
para evitar la revolución,
y hasta en eso falló.
¿Recuerda lo que pasó en 1905
luego de que sus tropas dispararon
contra los manifestantes pacíficos?"
"Sí, y el zar puso fin a la rebelión
presentando una constitución
y un parlamento electo, la Duma".
"Mientras, conservó el poder
absoluto y disolvía la Duma
cuando quería".
"Tal vez habría habido
más reformas a su debido tiempo
si los radicales, como Lenin,
no causaran siempre
tantos disturbios".
"Su Señoría, Lenin vio a su
hermano mayor, Aleksandr,
ejecutado por el zar anterior
por actividad revolucionaria,
e incluso luego de las reformas,
Nicolás continuó la misma
represión masiva y las ejecuciones,
así como la participación impopular
en la Primera Guerra Mundial
que costó a Rusia tantas
vidas y recursos".
"Mm, este zar no parece
un compañero tan cabal".
"Su Señoría, quizá Nicolás II
se autocondenó
por las malas decisiones,
pero Lenin no merece
confianza por esto.
Cuando los levantamientos
de febrero de 1917
finalmente obligaron
al zar a abdicar,
Lenin seguía exiliado en Suiza".
"Mm, entonces
¿quién asumió el poder?"
"La Duma formó un
gobierno provisional,
dirigido por Alexander Kerensky,
un fracasado burgués incompetente.
Incluso lanzó otra ofensiva
fallida durante la guerra
en la que Rusia
ya había perdido mucho,
en vez de terminarla
como la gente quería".
"Fue un gobierno
socialdemócrata constitucional,
el más progresista de su época.
Y podría haber triunfado finalmente
de no haber regresado Lenin en abril,
enviado por los alemanes para
socavar el esfuerzo de guerra ruso
e instigar los disturbios".
"¡Calumnia!
Las Jornadas de Julio fueron una
reacción espontánea y justificada
contra el fracaso del gobierno.
Y Kerensky mostró su verdadera cara
al culpar a Lenin,
arrestarlo y declarar ilegal
a su partido bolchevique,
obligándolo nuevamente
a exiliarse.
¡Democracia!
Es bueno que el gobierno se derrumbe
por su propia incompetencia y codicia.
Cuando intentaron un
golpe de estado militar
luego tuvieron que pedir ayuda
a los bolcheviques,
cuando les salió
el tiro por la culata.
Después de eso,
Lenin solo tuvo que
regresar en octubre
y hacerse cargo.
El gobierno fue derrocado pacíficamente
de la noche a la mañana".
"Pero lo que hicieron
los bolcheviques
al acceder al poder
no fue muy pacífico.
¿A cuántas personas ejecutaron
sin juicio?
¿Era realmente necesario
asesinar a toda la familia del zar,
incluidos a los niños?"
"Rusia estaba siendo atacada
por imperialistas extranjeros,
que trataban de restaurar al zar.
Cualquier heredero real rescatado
sería reconocido como soberano
por gobiernos extranjeros.
Habría sido el fin
de lo conseguido por
el pueblo en las luchas.
Además, Lenin no pudo
haber dado la orden".
"Pero los bolcheviques
no solo mataron a imperialistas.
¿Qué pasó con las
purgas y ejecuciones
de otros partidos
socialistas y anarquistas,
sus antiguos aliados?
¿Qué pasó con la Rebelión de Tambov,
en la que los campesinos, resistiendo
la confiscación de cereales,
fueron asesinados
con gas letal?
¿O con el envío del ejército
para aplastar a los
trabajadores de Kronstadt,
que reclamaban la
autogestión democrática?
¿Era eso luchar por el pueblo?"
"¡Sí! Las medidas fueron difíciles,
pero era un momento difícil.
El nuevo gobierno tenía que
garantizar su propia seguridad
mientras era atacado
por todos lados,
para establecer
el orden socialista".
"Y ¿qué salió de bueno de
este orden socialista?
Incluso después de ganada
la guerra civil,
hubo hambrunas, represión
y millones ejecutados
o enviados a morir en los campos,
mientras Stalin, el sucesor
de Lenin, establecía
un culto a la personalidad
y al poder absoluto".
"Ese no era el plan.
A Lenin nunca le importó
el rédito personal,
hasta sus enemigos admitieron
que él creía plenamente
en su causa,
que vivió modestamente
y trabajó sin descanso
desde sus días de estudiante
hasta su prematura muerte.
Al ver la ambición de poder de Stalin
trató de advertir al partido,
pero fue demasiado tarde".
"¿Y las décadas de totalitarismo
que siguieron después?"
"Puedes llamarlo así,
pero fueron los esfuerzos de Lenin
los que cambiaron Rusia
en pocas décadas,
de una monarquía atrasada
y subdesarrollada
repleta de campesinos analfabetos
a una superpotencia
industrial, moderna,
con una de las poblaciones
mejor formadas del mundo,
oportunidades sin precedentes
para las mujeres,
y algunos de los avances
científicos más importantes
del siglo.
La vida puede no fuera de lujo,
pero casi todo el mundo tenía techo
y comida,
algo que pocos
países han logrado".
"Pero esos avances
podrían haber ocurrido,
incluso sin Lenin
y el régimen represivo
que estableció".
"Sí, y yo podría haber sido
un famoso cantante de rock.
Pero ¿cómo habría sonado?"
Nunca podemos estar seguros de cómo
podrían haber ocurrido las cosas
de haber habido
otras personas en el poder
o de haber tomado
otras decisiones,
pero para evitar
los errores del pasado,
siempre debemos estar dispuestos
a poner en tela de juicio
a las figuras históricas.